K how long have we known each other now
gez like 10 years too long too long I
think it's about damn time that I do
this it's time for you to learn about
Sweden
no please anything that don't worry Ken
don't worry stop it stop because I made
it for Americans so it's easy to
understand hooray
yay we need to learn more about Sweden
you're always tell me about I have to
hear about the Swedish inventions all
the time and how great Sweden is though
you won't live there apparently it's
great well you summarized the whole
presentation for
me oh sorry I mean please
continue well first we're going to begin
with
geography that's right Ken can you do me
a favor point out Sweden on the map of
Europe I'm pointing is it here no it's
is it here no I don't even know what
that is that ain't it is it here no no
definitely not it's the one that looks
like a flaccid wiener part of it is you
did it
yes and the one across the water is the
ball sack that's right Finland is the
bull sack of Sweden you are correct and
Denmark could be considered a little
split split oh
yeah well done yay see I had faith in
you again I knew you were going to get
it do you use that analogy yourselves do
you guys think of it that way that's how
I remember yeah it was it was on news
and Sweden when they announced the Euro
cuz Norway is not part of Europe so the
co on the coin it looks like a penis and
it was a big International Scandal nice
Sweden is a
penis you may notice this little um blob
on the map what is that Ken look don't
ask me what any of that other stuff is I
know to it doesn't matter because I tell
you what it is it's not
Sweden it's
Switzerland oh they're two different
countries I don't ever want to hear in
my life oh you're from Sweden so like I
love your tools they're really good I'm
like yeah we have tools really good
tools the Swiss Harvey knives that yes
oh I love your chocolate oh we do have
chocolate that is correct and you're
skiing no well yes there is skiing don't
confuse Sweden with with the med pack
company they they're the video game med
pack flag
exactly first a kids Sweden is not
Switzerland but you knew that of
course yeah of course Switzerland has
expensive nice watches Rolex yes Sweden
has really cheap
knockoff because they're you know wiser
with your money people that wear Rolex
are just trying to flex and they're
probably that's right losers that's
right Switzerland has toon oh I don't
like toon I've never had it what I just
went oh
because seen it before how do you eat it
I know you're supposed to snap one off
but I just want to shove the whole thing
in my mouth and that's not comfortable
trust me I tried it it looks like with
something the police would throw out on
the road to pop your tires if you're
speeding away that's right stupid
chocolate they put like some nut in
there I don't like it then we have
marabu so good marabu and they of course
have this Swiss army knife there is yeah
yeah in Sweden we have the spoon also
known as so now that we learned the
difference between Sweden and
Switzerland we can now move on to some
famous Swedish people SL figures oh and
I'm going to go ahead and let you why do
I sound Italian I don't
know know you go ahead and you name
three you want me to name three Swedish
okay one is easy all right Felix
shellberg you got damn right peie
pie going to give you a hint on the next
one
okay wait is this from euro vision come
on come on the be no it's not BG's uh H
not
heart who are the uh Spice Girls and boy
dancing queen young I know the song I
don't know who sung it
ABA it's ABA ABA how can you not know
Abba that's not their name is it yes it
is
I I've seen that the name before and I
thought it was just like an abbreviation
for something like
Abba like it stands for something it's
just ABA oh what do you think the
abbreviation was awesome band Yes
B beautifully awesome you know I'll take
that all right you're sitting down right
I am sitting yes I want you to sit for
the next one okay I'm s cuz as an
American this might be troubling
disturbing shocking who is is this man
and I know for a fact you have noing
clue who that
is you're right I do not have
Celsius and Celsius that's Celsius
mother that's right I knew you didn't
know Celsius you filthy American where's
where's Fahrenheit at oh
God get it interrupting video for a
special an time I made a presentation
pay close attention first of all guest
today's sponsor I'll give you a hint
you're never going to get this you're
never going to get this you're never
going to get this
nordvpn the best VPN something was there
we go I know it has Nord in it but don't
worry it's not Norwegian I
think right now as you know I'm not in
Sweden I'm in
Japan or am I that's right with a simple
click of a button I can change countries
B back in my Homeland n VPN is fast you
may have seen free vpns but they're
trash something something ass okay I'm
out here living large watching whatever
show that damn pleases me because that's
how it should be there should be no
restrictions on the internet I'm
watching Myster P home getting them that
Christmas spirit it's okay cuz I'm in
Sweden how would they know prove it
prove that I'm not you can't I don't
know why I added that nor VPN more VPN
with amazing features such as threat
protection and file protection now I'm
going to tell you an embarrassing story
there oh it doesn't stop spinning okay
this is me as a dumb little child I
clicked on something I wasn't supposed
to do we had to scrap our whole family
computer these days everything is online
I have all my photos online shows that I
paid for all of this stays safe behind
Next Generation wall of encryption
threat protection scans whatever dumb
thing you want to click on and you don't
be the dumb boy like I was it's safe to
use and your data will never be
compromised by nordvpn it works on
multiple devices use it on your phone as
well after six at the same time you get
also bigger PP I threw that one in there
I don't know if that actually does
anything now use the link nordvpn.com
PewDiePie for 4 month additional bonus
bonus try out for 30 days money back
guarantee bonus bonus use the link n
n.com PewDiePie you're welcome thank you
that concludes my presentation why n VPN
best VPN that's right Ken Sweden
invented Celsius all right now you got
to tell me why V Celsius is
better I don't think there's much to say
cuz it's obvious to anyone firenight is
only used by Americans and some few
other people in the whole world you do
realize you're the only one it's yeah
yeah we also measur in feet you know
instead of yeah but but the UK does that
stupid I don't know oh do they they
measure their feet yes they do and
stones and anyway Celsius Fahrenheit Z
Dee water 100° water it boils oh so
simple so simple and they they also like
convert into each other very easy too
like Zer to 100 thank you I I thought
you would resist fit sounds
dumb Fahrenheit it's like a was there a
video game called Fahrenheit No but
there's a novel and it sucks that's was
a novel right yeah adding little
pictures fan Celsius enjy just come on
man what do you think in Celsius is hot
like if it's hot outside if it's hot so
I've been in Australia so now I've kind
of getting I've gotten you know train
but it's like if it's above 30 it's it's
pretty warm outside pretty hot that's
right that's correct all right you
actually get American pass
congratulations thank you thank you
Sweden has many great Innovations as I'm
sure you know Ken M
I don't know if I mentioned this to you
before all the time I mean yeah never
never what has swen invented can you
name some what haven't they invented
right clearly you don't listen they've
done so much Jesus Christ you know they
the Ikea they've invented Ikea and the
spoon and meatballs you see their SC no
they did they
cocacola you see you think it's American
also American we love our Coca-Cola over
here in fact Ken I think what might
surprise you is that the bottle was
invented by Sweden oh the bottle yes the
bottle the iconic bottle oh you you'll
let us have the bottle well I was going
to say you know it makes sense that
Sweden would think it was a good idea to
put like cocaine and a drink like they
did originally but never mind I guess
that was still an American
thing I bet you didn't know that how
about this huh Alfred Nobel the Nobel
Awards you've heard of that sure yeah
yes in of dynamite we like to make
things boom just like you Ken I'm
learning so much you know history is not
an American strong point at all because
we never learned from it but I'm
impressed to know that the the Nobel
Prize guy invented dynamite
yeah there's a bomb Oh those thing yeah
you ever used one of those yes I have
yeah they're very handy that's right
they are you want to you want your
garden host to strap on a little tighter
just give that thing a twirl and you're
good
give some Plumbing just tighten it up a
chopping board that's it looks like a
chopping board it's a plastic bag how
dare they no no no no no our intentions
were puin oh they invented this thinking
oh it's plastic bag people are going to
reuse
it this is such a good
[Laughter]
idea how wrong they were oh how wrong
everyone's like [__] I just throw it in
trash I'm done with this yeah yeah they
actually thought people would bring them
to the store I guess people kind of do
now with the fancy ones but that was the
intention with the plastic bag that's
the sweds andan oh we could do that here
um like we we'll get delivery like we'll
have them delivered uh to our door
sometimes our groceries and if we keep
the plastic bags and give them to them
they'll take them and oh yes supposedly
reuse them yes of course reuse
them you like propellers I love
propellers first one Swedish wow yeah
was that the first one right there huge
one I bet it
wasn't you you know Ikea glorious
motherland the mother yeah fantastic
Spotify
Minecraft adjustable wrench wow I have
one of those thank you Sweden thank you
you're welcome are you taking CR
yeah the seat belt that's right the
three-point seat belt the zipper the
zipper you use it every day probably
don't wear real pants like a true
American and as a true American I bet
you like cutting bolts oh yeah Bol
cutter bulb Cutters wow ball bearing you
like spinny fidget Spinners thank you
sweet my God that's right ball bearings
are pretty cool is how long is this list
what all they have what is that Tira Pac
it's a cart paper carton of stuff they
made the carton as well yes we did I
drink out milk cartons when I was a kid
that's right you should thank a sweet
every time but most importantly of all
can we invent that and I'm actually
genely proud of this the
a cream separator where would I be in
life without the ab cream separator what
what is that what is that do it
separates the cream what
it from what
itself and B I don't
know you got the a cream and the B cream
but they're separate now
and we got the ab separator look at this
beautiful image oh brings tear to my
eyes such wonderful use of
abam
separator so I want you to say thanks
you should thank a site any chance you
get for its many Innovations and
contributions to the world you use the
zipper thank you Sweden thank you
Sweden did you show this to Maria if you
show it to me no I haven't actually she
glanced at it and she was like what the
F she like very
good so let's compare American
Image I thought the end of it okay all
right fair enough let's compare peanut
butter wow incredible where would I be
without peanut butter so skinny and
small potato potato chips yes not crisps
oh oh what is that an
Abomination corn dog sir that is a that
is a American Pastime right there eating
corn dog the the stick goes halfway up
that that dog right there and you kind
of eat around it is it good they're
Prett they're pretty tasty they also got
breakfast ones too that have like
pancake batter around the dog instead
sausage inside why am I not surprised of
course you can dip it in in Honey or you
know molasses whatever you want oh what
is that tater tots tater tods where are
all these
food I don't know you tell me
I don't know Americans loved eat all
right we know it tastes good if you can
deep fry it the hamburger the trip
Triple Decker hamburger and a coke knot
in that glass from Sweden that's what
I'm talking about that's what I like to
see right there good American Glass
thank you America truly as well I didn't
want to just come here and you know talk
about all Sweden's invention oh the
brownie as well oh I I love brownies too
God this this looks like a like a good
weekend to me right here like this 4th
of July get the burgers and the corn
dogs and the peanut butter tater tots
you truly are American K you truly are
but one thing about the burger though
listen you people out there in your
fancy Burger shops stop making your
Burgers taller they're hard can't chew
them how am I supposed to bite mouth
around it thank you just make them
flatter and wider I guess you want to
make how do they expect it if it's this
tall like how am I supposed to eat it
okay so you might wonder what kind of
food does Sweden have oh okay all
the first one's easy mhm oh is it is it
the meatball that's right
meatball glorious meatball is that
potatoes and what is the other thing
mashed potatoes and lingan berries the
PewDiePie geuel flavor it's beautiful
kill PewDiePie than go it's a tartness
that goes perfect with the brown sauce H
I cook food sometimes once a year maybe
every other year and if I make meatballs
and you don't eat the linger berries
you're dead to me okay okay oh I
understand this has happened many times
before they look at the lingan berries
and they're like it looks fun weird I
don't want to you have to eat the lingan
berries do not say you like meatballs
and let you eat the linger berries my
mouth is salivating just talking
about the sweeden is coming out you got
to eat
them so can you name another one I cuz I
could like this is hard for me too to be
honest the Hot Pocket no but you know
this one sud stroming well I have no
idea what that is what is that it's the
thing that smells like death you never
heard of this I mean is that why
everybody's covering their face up while
they're opening it in this picture this
is like a YouTube thing you never what
what I didn't never do those stupid
challenges well good because last time I
did it I almost
died it is the most foul stench you've
ever smelled times 100 it's illegal to
open these at an airport because it's
consider a deed of terrorism you're
supposed to open it underwater and it's
good apparently I don't eat it would you
eat underwater too like I don't know you
need a gas mask to eat it but it's a
Swedish food glorious therefore it's
glorious SE string very nice and we also
have you know this one is this breakfast
no no no it's a word it's a Swedish word
that Americans love to say and I don't
understand why uh smart
spon are you just waiting for me to be
confused so you can throw these words at
me yeah I always hear you say it or
people they're like oh Sweden like
smuggers Bo I love it hang on I need
Mary for this cuz one second hang on I
think she said this here Mary you say
you say the word that I think it's a
different word though Shak oh no you
made me say it wrong I didn't do
anything shakery board a sh a shakery
board shakery board the is that the
Shakur board it's the board you have
where your chees stuff SM board
Shakur boy shakuri means meat and cheese
what language I don't
know me either maybe people in the
comments maybe it means something else
in a different I don't know the same
thing all right drinks we have drinks I
just feel like you need to know about
this okay okay okay yeah you must you
know what that is sounds it sounds gross
it sounds like like mu must that's what
it is you
it means Christmas must Christmas or no
Christmas foam I guess or yeah I don't
know how to transyl say it's like Coke
but it's foamy and we drink it every
Christmas and it's delicious it's got to
be better than eggnog I don't know why
people drink that well yeah EG is
disgusting so typically typically you
Americans associate Christmas with
Coca-Cola we do we though they kind of
force that on they try to force that
that's right that's right they do those
don't abuse us with the image of s Santa
and our precious Hearts getting stolen
the ultimate capitalist Santa Claus well
capitalism hasn't worked for us there
because every December UL must stock
prices kazoo over Coca-Cola C Co we
drink Yos do you drink it yeah I love it
it's the best so would you drink it like
I don't like now like any other time no
that's forbidden you have to drink it
during Christmas okay oh my God say
don't your American values how dare you
it's good you know if you can just enjoy
it no if we do have it for Easter too
but that's it if you drink it any other
time people look at you like what the is
wrong with you put that down so yeah I
just wanted to show the phone the foam
is the important bit you got to slurp
the foam I am white as on camera the sun
is hitting straight into the
lens your precious Jes
Christ stop it son oh my God just look
at yourself you're just like out like
nuking my camera the summer solstice
it's shining upon you your in your
sweetest Glory you spread the good word
of ulist
no the sun is moving okay just going to
hold up this book it's how you absorb
knowledge you just hold it up I'm want
to time with this presentation Ken I got
to keep moving we also have vodka but
yeah who cares all right so Ken can you
answer who is this
it's Donald Duck no no isn't no it's K
mother flipping anchor
okay kala Anka that's right kala Anka
and PFF puff poof piff puff poof you D
you told me about this where was Chip
Andale it's the
same in Sweden we don't give a about
this guy all right get him out of here
Donald Duck is what it's all about
we love Donald Duck oranka I think it's
important to know I was waiting I
already saw in my head I was like he's
going to hit me with the freaking boner
Donald in a
minute what other image can I
use the best one I it really personifies
what what he is just a Chad he is a Chad
beta Mickey Mouse well anyway we have
the comic book that you saw earlier but
also we have a weird Swedish tradition
you maybe know about this this is
Christmas in Sweden at 300 p.m. everyone
watches Donald do huh yeah 3 p.m. on
Christmas they haven't even opened the
presents yet no usually like after yeah
that would make sense I don't know maybe
before it depends yeah we all watch
religiously Donald Duck we love it so
much who's this channel St svt1 Swedish
TV it's the government one okay what are
some things you should never say to a
Sweden that they might be Switzerland
that's right that's one you're learning
I appreciate appreciate that we've
already been through that however oh
this don't stop bringing this Swedish
racist stereotype I don't want to hear
it it's too accurate that it's not funny
I never heard I never heard a Swedish
person think this guy's funny we all
take offense I've brought this guy up to
you several times to was a joke too you
never laugh yeah maybe get the idea Ken
it's not
funny I I know number two okay what is
it that Sweden invented husqavarna yeah
well we did did we not you did oh is
that how you say it though does that
bother you how I say husar no it's kind
of cute I appreciate
it well you shouldn't say however is oh
you're cold but you're
Swedish we feel the cold just like
anyone else what do you mean it makes it
so like I can't complain about being
cold cuz cuz I know some will come under
my shoulder and go well I thought you
were Swedish surprise surprise I still
get Cal last but not least Ken what
should you never bring up to a sued do
you Worship the Great Odin or Thor or
tier Norway Norway never say anything
good about Norway I don't want to hear
it have I told you about Norway tell me
about Norway okay so for to go to
Norway
God have a slide ready for it wow fell
into that one all
right Sweden has had many
worse we had STX tden we had the Viking
tden we fought everyone for a while tden
it was pretty cool we have long history
of fighting Ken but we also fight
amongst ourselves just like you Ken oh
the denmarks and the swedes the nors and
the swedes the norways and the denmarks
the the denmarks and then swedes there
for back and forth and then everyone
hates Sweden for some reason I don't get
it every noric country were they making
fun of us I don't get it what do we do
then in um I don't remember when 1300s
this Danish Queen came in and was like
you guys should stop fighting let's all
be friends I think that's how it went
down and we became friends wow yeah it
was beautiful no Ken it wasn't beautiful
okay Sweden strong
independent woman we want it out okay
you can Style on this image we don't
like these guys then this Legend showed
up gustava you know gustava of course
mhm this
guy nice legs thank
you there's a fun fact about this I'm
glad you brought this up apparently he
saw one of the soldiers I was like that
guy has nice legs paint me those
legs those are not his legs those are
not his legs that's like the world's
first Photoshop I was gonna say like I
don't know if his jacket's too big or if
the legs are small like those legs man
those are fine draw those uh he
separated us from all this B that's a
long history here so I'm just going to
fast forward why Norway is bad okay
first of all they killed our King not
cool in the 1700s apparently they shot
their King I feel like you would be
pissed if someone did that to
you it's not not cool man
you may have noticed he's being carried
out on a giant pillow yeah as was ironic
cuz he was shot in the
head is that his face yeah I think he
yeah I think he's dead it looks like the
freaking NS veratu
vampire we weren't so pretty back then
Ken I just love they they gave him a
pillow it's like motherfucker's
dead well he got shot in the head you
know he got beautiful image beautiful
drawing all right more history speedrun
just so you can know why Norway is bad
we had a French kid king for a while
it's weird French King Sean Baptist or
something like that uh he complained I
remember in history class he complained
that Sweden was so cold right yeah yeah
so I guess he wasn't Swedish then cuz he
felt the cold he the cold then we took
over Norway finally and it looked like
this from the
1800s to the
1905 for a 100 years Norway was like
please can we independent I don't know
how to how toes know it sound like just
really dumb can we be independent can
you and Sweden's like no there's legs
though yeah legs in Sweden is a
thing but then finally we were like okay
fine just fine Norway you can go you can
leave us after 100 years we gave up
Norway super happy they celebrate their
independence and they do it way more
than sweets which I don't like all right
they're way happier about it they
celebrate too much yeah tone it down a
bit Norway Jesus Christ and then of
course you know this happened Norway
finds a trillion dollar it's not my
fault all right no you should be mad you
hunt oil all the time you're American
you might wonder okay why does Sweden
not have the oil it was our land okay we
took Norway we just let them go we
deserve that money it's like if if I
give you something useless and then you
sell it on eBay for 2 billion I want a
piece of that trillion at the very least
all of it and then go but no you gave it
to me it's mine I can do what it doesn't
matter because I had it first so I
should at least get you what you gave it
to me it was trash to you and you know I
just took advantage of the situation yes
it was trash to me but now I want it
back actually I want it back friends
anymore now no it doesn't matter because
it's mine now no it's mine okay well see
what happens Nori wasn't sure that they
had found all the oil first they were
like I think there's something over here
sweds hey sweds think we found something
uh and they wanted yeah this is Norway
finding oil uh they I ran out of time
okay uh Norway said to Sweden if you
give us 40% of your Volvo precious Volvo
your wonderful safe cars we will let you
in on this oil that we think we found
and we're like no you're not touching
our volleball you already got too much
right you don't deserve anything it's
like it's if I give you something you
sell it on eBay for a trillion
and then you want something more out of
me but we could both make money why are
you on their side so yeah they were like
oh we think we find all Let's Make a
Deal Sweden says no that we're not doing
a deal we Vol too precious for us what
happens boom
$1.1
trillion it makes me sick just looking
at it honestly more than China should
have gave him some Volvo man I don't
know I know k I know cuz as I'm sure you
know Volvo eventually sold in
China so what the what was the point of
that sweds have never really recovered
from this at least I haven't it hurts me
every day as you can see is you playing
like The Walking Dead back in the day
that's no that I was looking at Norway's
[Music]
GDP well Ken you may think wow this is
pretty bad for Sweden but it get worse
it can't get worse no it get no it gets
worse it gets worse North Korea you see
this North Korean gentlemen uhhuh what
car is he driving Ken definitely not a
Volvo that is a Volvo oh no yeah you
think you paid for that Volvo Ken yes so
basically in the 1970s this has been
marked in history as one of the worst
business deals after the Norway Fiasco
where North Korea came to Sweden and was
like hey cool cars you got there could
you send us a couple of those we send
thousands we're like okay here you go
North Korea you repal North Korea here's
the cars worth of millions and millions
anyway here's the billing pay whenever
it's convenient for you they still
haven't paid us 50 years and I don't
think they're going to pay us I just
don't for some reason I don't know why I
don't think it's going to happen man is
Volvo doing youing idiots you it so hard
I curse wo God damn should this go on
the list of things I should never ask a
Swedish person about I think so yes even
no yeah yes it does Ken yes it does what
is this Volvo on the right is this
scrapping all the cars throwing my
probably probably because now fast
forward today Volvo sld to China so it
didn't matter second we import Norway's
trash that's what we do now so so you're
telling me the Norway's over there
living it up with all their money and we
get their and they send Sweden their
trash so that you can create heat and
electricity do you pay for the trash
most likely we're
idiots but it's okay Ken because Sweden
we have F I don't know if you heard
about this a coffee yes it's a coffee
break call it f it's awesome usually you
have a lemonade or sft as we call it
with the kenel bu our King wears really
funny
hats that's cool right and Sweden twice
population of Norway that's way better
right okay and we have Midsummer
wonderful tradition we the kakaka yeah
yeah so we have the world famous that
everyone knows yeah Abba uhuh that's
right yeah and of course PewDiePie they
don't have him anymore let's be honest
he mov to Japan he's gone and that's why
Sweden is the best
country
yay sweet the best country
ever which is why I don't live there
anymore because I want everyone else to
enjoy you removed yourself for everybody
and this is for you guys should you
should thank your thank your PewDiePie
Sweden I hope this was educational and
that you learned a lot I learned a whole
lot wow I really understand Sweden now
and it is the best it's the best don't
say that you have your potato chips and
your hamburger yeah I got
hamburgers